こんにちははじめ社長です良いをなす本番豆来る日も際に多いんですけれども
はレンタル品に腫れてる気に雨降ってる時たまにないですか
あれをやりたい
あれやりたいと言いますかちょっと雨降ってるって錯覚させてみたいんですねまぁ何を
するかと言いますと今日めちゃくちゃ天気いいんですよペン議員ですけどもなんとか
装置を使って俺ん家の周りだけ&よフラしてオレンジのまでだけ雨をクラスとですよ
えって度上げてや晴れてるのに雨降ってるなぁと思って肩をそっと思って片岡氏
desoto いくんですけども俺の家の周りしか雨降ってないんでああいうふうに傘
を差してどこかへ行くというめちゃくちゃダサい映画飛べるんじゃないかなと思いまし
て今回俺ん家の周りだけ雨を膨らせみたいと思いますねちゃテンキーのに傘を察する
最低にダサい構図作っていきますというわけで装置がこちらでございます
[音楽]
ぞ
ぶー牧場力1
ばいいんじゃないかなって
[音楽]
これを置くぞに持ってきたわけだ
th
me
ねぇ
p 主
[音楽]
wh
めっちゃさんと出る夏とそのドイツたところはこれは何か曇ってるしいい感じに姉じゃ
ないですかねこれ
というわけで
ちょっと何かを持っている曇ってきててがリアルなんですけども
外に出たら家の周りだけ雨降ってる時になっていきたいとおもいます
ポジあのさぁはいもしもしちょっとさスマイル公園のさ
それからジャンキャプテンちょっとあそこでジュース1本買ってきてもらっていい一人
で声がお願いします
はい
[音楽]
[拍手]
fo
[音楽]
ん
そうで4分
[音楽]
ん
うん
[音楽]
ここだ極めるんです
ああああああ
計算
[音楽]
そう今はなぁ
tee
[音楽]
[拍手]
くん
うん
あっは
[音楽]
blr